a ball of fire pierces the atmosphere of
mars
plummeting towards the surface at 13
200 miles per hour
this fireball across the horizon marks
the end of a 301 million mile journey
for nasa's insight
and the beginning of a groundbreaking
mission
for five decades nasa probes have
explored the exterior of the martian
landscape and atmosphere
but now for the first time the insight
lander will go deeper than ever before
inside the ancient mysteries of the red
planet
what's inside mars
and how can the red planet
help us better understand our own
go atlas go inside
this is the atlas v
on may 5th 2018 it became the first
rocket to launch an interplanetary
mission from the west coast of the
united states
cruising through space for 205 days
inside will fly almost halfway around
the sun and eventually intersect with
its final destination mars
the fourth planet from the sun
mars is the second smallest in the solar
system
it's a rocky planet like earth but much
of what's inside is still a mystery
to give us a window into mars deep
interior
nasa's inside lander will check the
planet's vital signs for clues
unlike previous mars missions this probe
will stay in one place for the duration
of its mission
first it will check its pulse
its sensitive seismometer will gauge
vibrations from meteor impacts or
marsquakes caused by shifting rocks
listening to these shakes and quakes
will make it possible for us to
determine the depth and composition of
its crust mantle and core
next insight will check the planet's
temperature
its heat probe will burrow deep
underground up to a depth of 16 feet
beneath the martian surface
this groundbreaking device will measure
the planet's interior temperatures and
track how they fluctuate throughout the
year
to complete its checkup insight will
test the reflexes of mars by measuring
small changes in a radio signal from
earth
[Music]
this will show us how much the planet
wobbles in its rotation which can give
us clues about its core composition
if mars has a liquid core its rotation
will be more wobbly
and if its core is more solid we'll see
less wobbling
when studied together these vital signs
will give us valuable insight into rocky
planets as well as improve our
understanding of how they form
[Music]
it's exciting to consider the future
possibilities of human habitation on
mars
[Music]
but as we look forward
we must also make sure to look backwards
to learn from our solar system's ancient
past
who knows what secrets the universe
might reveal
[Music]
[Music]
you